voilà ça s'appelle là bas mon pays c'est
un film d'alexandre arcady et qu'antoine
de caunes samy naceri ça sort le 12
avril voilà ce que je voulais dire c'est
que moi j'ai arkani c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a fait rêver qui m'a donné envie de
faire du cinéma et je rêvais de tourner
avec lui et l'a donc j'ai une
participation amicale et j'avais envie
de jouer ce rôle de ce mec qui se bat
pour la liberté en 62 et qui se bat
encore aujourd'hui pour la liberté et
mon personnage est important pour le
dénouement de l'histoire et que c'est
une belle participation amicale quoi
c'est très émouvant - tous les cas ça
m'a beaucoup touché une sortie de l'ag
beau votre père est venu en france en
cas quelle époque il est venu bien avant
l'indépendance
il est venu bien avant des dépendances
il vendait des fleurs dans les halles
il a rencontré ma mère qui est normande
qui est normande qui explique les yeux
bleus à la gare saint lazare et ils sont
plus quittés c'est pas beau si on lui a
demandé de porter les valises et depuis
alors votre père était donc peintre en
bâtiment après oui vous avez une enfance
assez modeste dans un deux pièces six
enfants dans la même chambre
mais c'était bien ouais ouais et puis
après mon père essayé de taper pour
qu'on bouge un peu quoi donc la peinture
il en a fait un vrai métier quoi donc il
s'est battu pour qu'on bouge de là où en
était et pour nous donner une vraie
éducation puis enfin de quoi aller à
l'école et qui et puis j'avais ma mère
qui était là aussi pour veiller à tout
ça et mais on était tous ensemble dans
cette chambre j'ai emmené mes frères et
soeurs mais c'était bien c'est là où on
a commencéà j'ai commencé et puis mes
frères aussi à nourrir des rêves de
cinéma et or faisait toutes les scènes
des films d euros défaut si vous faisiez
des musées des péplums voilà un y'avait
dire qu'il y avait il y avait il y avait
un rideau qui séparait la chambre des
enfants de chambre des parents et ils
étaient dans la chambre des enfants
évidemment et il faisait des péplums il
jouait recul et cléopâtre on va vous
rappeler des souvenirs
e
samy naceri bons amis vous pourriez
jouer d'un foyer jouer dans un grand
club
j'aimerais bien vous avez vous avez
vraiment la tête à jouer dans un album
le dernier qu'on avait avant vous
c'était cédric pioline donc avis aux
producteurs vous êtes bon comme la
romaine bien qu'allant tout de suite
votre idole ça a était gamin dit si
j'arrive à avoir 20% de l'amour que les
français portent à gabin je serai ravi
ce sera vraiment un aboutissement dans
ma vie ouais c'est un mec
je veux dire tout ce qu'il a fait tout
ce qu'il a touché il a joué des rôles
complètement différent je veux dire les
misérables le singe en hiver le clan des
siciliens et je vais le parrain il joue
un avocat il joue un flic qui joue un
commissaire ghazouani dans la ville
ouais tout ça ouais c'est le mec et
ouais franchement si si je pourrai wells
la semaine 10 % 10 % et 7 mai gueule si
on est pour cent là on est à 10 % évolue
ce que je disais cet après midi j'aurai
voulu arriver dans deux cinémas et avoir
ma petite place dans le cinéma ou gaben
était encore là il ne serait ce que de
me retrouver sur un plateau avec lui et
pouvoir parler un petit peu avec lui
quoi et une selle alors ça aurait été
merveilleux faut se méfier quand on dit
je voudrais 10%
pour ce qui est de gabao parce que y'en
a un qui voudraient 10% de belmondo et
s'appelle michel creton l'attention
alors on vous rêviez vous rêviez à jean
gabin l'école bon ce n'est pas très très
très bien passée c'était lent pension
cette fin plus jeter est un joueur
annoncé à vos parents que vous voulez
être comédien et il vous dit qu'on
redescend sur terre va bosser au marché
que tes frères quoi hélas malgré tout
obligé avec rues en vert et contre tous
et je me suis dit j'ai dit j'ai vous y
croyez pas c'est un peu ralenti arrivera
pas à mon pote c'est pas possible
j'y arriverai pas et je me suis tapé
comme un fou jallet alors je n'étais pas
préparée j'arrivais avec deux trois
photos complètement nul décév et mal
taper depuis je me suis fait jeter
toutes les portes à se fermer et
bah ouais qui sait comment vous êtes
pieds sami quoi quoi la crise menace et
non vous rigolez bon ok on va mais j'ai
pas le temps là d'accord et puis je suis
tombé sur un mec bruno de l'est ouais
qui m'a été présenté par ma prof de
théâtre et c'est lui qui m'a mis le pied
à l'étrier schiller kid le problème de
gilles de maistre 1 vous venez de
refaire un film si le domaine dans
lequel vous êtes ainsi pas loin des
regards sont fidèles celui qui vous a
donné votre première chance et
aujourd'hui vous êtes le star et vous
travailler avec lui ça s'appelle féroce
ouais on se disait tu rappelles sami il
ya eu huit entités avec moi qui leur kit
tu faisais tu avais une petite figure et
aient été coupés au montage j'en avais
parlé à tout le monde sa vie racontée à
tout le monde tu vas voir j'ai fait un
film on ne sait pas dans le film c'est
vrai j'étais gt gt comme un fou j'avais
dit à mes parents à tout le monde vous
avez vu dit non c'est pas possible et
tout machin déjà le faire un film je
suis resté 15 jours sur le film là et
venez venez je suis arrivé j'attendais
ma scène j'attendais ma 5.1 moment donné
au fond et puis débouche mais si vous
êtes arrivé une autre fois c'est vrai il
faut dire la vérité quand vous avez
connu besson juillet dans dans les
rayons avec une cagoule et à la fin du
tournage b110 quand même le pauvre samy
naceri on le voit pas quand même donc ça
serait quand même bien qu'on le voit
dans le dernier jour ils du coup tu
enlèves ta cagoule comme ça on va devoir
mais c'était une série d une belle
rencontre
une belle rencontre et et la gg j'ai
senti que
que le mec qu'il s'intéressait à moi
quoique que j'étais là et il parlait
avec les techniciens il me regardait
comme ça et puis il ya nuit machin et je
suis arrivé donc dans les moulins de
paris il y avait une scène où jean reno
se déguise en soit et puis il fait
semblant de se sauver il est blessé donc
les autres soit l'aide à sortir les
mâles y tiens ça me tue l'avenir méritée
on et acadiennes jean reno donc c'est
génial pour moi tu fais une cents avec
jean reno et au montage et de la fumée
partout et on voit rien alors on va voir
les phoques des galères de samy naceri
l'époque des répondeurs son message le
soir aidé des castings inutile magnéto
servent